we're making I'm alone okay let's go
over the night you can only show two
pictures of your kids tonight and you
can only check in twice what can I get
you okay how sharp my face yeah I'll get
the same but can you fill it like a
fourth Bowl because if I have any more
I'm just gonna pass out right here well
yeah that's good that's good Jackson
hasn't pooped and I just wanted to see
if he had yet oh my god you did it now
tell me what color was it was it more of
a yellow or a green you're not being
descriptive enough just you know just
send me a picture
does this look runny to you let me zoom
in hold on what guys does this always
love the song hello there's not a
Jackson I like to dance to it like oh
this is not really don't do that in
public thank you
what are you looking at you know
actually looking at it was my unit come
closer come come here come on sit over
here sure it's my son's fourth birthday
party photos he looks so cute it was
circus-themed so this is his second
birthday party now it was a Western
thing my husband dressed up as a cowboy
look at this one your husband you hungry
I can only that's not what you bring to
a wall if we're drinking we have two
snacks this has been such a fun night
I'm gonna head out I'm with my kids I'll
see you next month that's when we put in
our
I need a break
excuse me would you mind does this look
runny to you it's my son's food